now wait the kids call the neighbors put
your phones down we've got the lowdown
now on what's up ten minutes past 6:00
in a Friday morning yeah host of Las
Vegas now in Mercedes in the morning
Mercedes Martinez joining us from the
mix 94.1 studio with what's trending
today
happy Friday Mercedes how you doing
you're doing great Alex John so great to
see you guys this morning let's get
right to it what's trending Kelly
Clarkson is trending again this morning
it's been a crazy week for her she it
was newly separated a lot of bad news
there but some good news finally she's
gonna be getting her own star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame it was just
announced that she along with a bunch of
other celebrities Missy Elliott the
Judds Trisha Yearwood salt-and-pepper if
you remember those guys they're all
gonna be getting stars on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame so that's very good news
for her this morning yeah a little bit
of some sugar with some of the
unpleasant things in there happening
recently some of us in this building are
fantastic dancers but we want a way to
like take advantage of our dancing
prowess particularly when it comes to
burgers do you know any sort of solution
to this dilemma I've got the perfect
solution for you first of all John
download' tick-tock I know you are on
tick-tock right yeah okay so tick-tock
is actually teaming up with Burger King
to give you $1 whoppers and all you got
to do is dance it's as simple as that go
- tick-tock follow Burger King and then
do some sort of a dance
Burger King will then DM you a code so
that you can get a $1 whopper and all it
does is it's just showing us your little
moves let's see your moves you guys got
some loose going come on Langley no I
gotta wait I gotta get the burger
yeah and then you can do the tick-tock
with the burger yeah no one needs to say
no I'm really gonna follow you right now
it's Wrangler moves is in a couple of
days on Sunday and give me sometimes
hard to find the perfect gift for Dad
yeah it really is and here's the thing
we know what not to get dad the new poll
shows that there are certain things that
dads do not want for Father's Day and
the number one thing is clothes oh my
gosh I've already got my husband like a
shirt or something but dads do not want
clothes for Father's Day now another
thing on the list books CDs they don't
want what's the number one thing that
dads do want well because of this
pandemic they just want to stay home and
relax do a little backyard barbecue but
something that is really interesting
that came out of this poll is that the
worst gift giver for father's day in the
family our sons sons are not stepping up
for dad
Oh No why is that I wonder what my
tradition not maybe the time yeah well
so for my father in the last couple
years I've gotten him like golf stuff
okay so like I'll pay I'll get
certificate to go play golf just because
it's a way to get out and it's something
to do and you get out of the house and
you can you know and if you enjoys golf
that's that's you know one thing to do
certainly no clothes and I haven't
bought a CD in about 15 years with the
golf Big John you win too because he can
take you and then you both get a gift
there I'm just saying it works both ways
just do it before it gets super hot
outside it's a great gift
all right Mercedes Martinez will let you
get back to 94.1 thank you for joining
us and say Happy Father's Day dear
husband watching you guys
we're gonna listen after the program
thanks for all right so no clothes and
no CDs get as a gift Father's Day
that'll go over on tick-tock